اهلا بكم الى موجز لي اهم الانباء اعلنت
الولايات المتحده والسعوديه تعليق محادثات
جدا بشان السودان بصفتهما رعيتي المفاوضات
وقال بيان للسفاره الامريكيه في الخرطوم
ان قرار واشنطن والرياض ياتي نتيجه
الانتهاكات الجسيمه المتكرره لوقف اطلاق
النار قصير الامد من جانب القوات المسلحه
السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع
وكانت الاداره الامريكيه اعلنت فرد عقوبات
على شركات تصنيع دفاعي سودانيه وشركتين
مملكتين لحميتي تمدان قوته بالسلاح والمال
وقد عبر جون كربي منسقه الاتصالات في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي عن امله ان يدرك
البرهان واحميتي الجديه في معاقبه من
يعرقل التوصل لحل سياسي في السودان وقال
كوربي للجزيره ان هدف العقوبات هو اعاده
مسار المحادثات
من جاته قال السفر السوداني في واشنطن
للجزيره ان فرض عقوبات على مؤسسات الدوله
السودانيه يعني فرض عقوبات على الشعب
السوداني
قال رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان واشنطن لا
تسعى الى صراع مع بيجين لكنها ستقف الى
جانب اصدقائها واضاف ان بلاده تعزز امنها
في منطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادئ وتعمل
مع شركائها لمواجهه ما سماها تهديدات
كوريا الشماليه
من جيتي احتجت بيجين على توقيع واشنطن
اتفاقات تجاريه مع تايوان وقالت ان
التعاون العسكريه بين واشنطن وطوكيو يجب
ان لا يضر بمصالح طرف ثالث
افد حكيم مقاطعه
ان طائرتين
هاجمتان لتقرير النفط في المقاطعه
المحاذيه لبيلاروسيا دون تسجيل اضرار تذكر
بدوره قال حاكم مقاطعه كالوجا الروسيه ان
الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت طائره مسيره
اوكرانيه فوق احدى الغابات في المقاطعه
ودعنا ابو رئيس مجلس الامن القومي الروسي
الى القضاء على ما وصفه بالنظام الاوكراني
الذي اعتبره تهديدا مستمرا لروسيا
من جهته طلب الرئيس
الاوكرانيتو المقبله بضمانات امنيه وتسريع
انضمام بلاده لحلف شمال الاطلسي
يواصل سيربو كوسوفو الاحتجاج لليوم الخامس
امام مقر ربا ثلاث بلديات شمالي كوسوفو
ويطالب المحتاجون بسحب تعزيزات الشرطه من
امام المباني العامه وعدم السماح لرؤساء
البلديات من اصول البانيه المنتخبين اخيرا
بالدخول الى المقر
وقال قائد قوات حفظ السلام التابعه للنيتو
في كوسوفو ان الوضع خطير جدا واضاف في
مقابله مع الجزيره انه لابد من ايجاد حل
يعيد الطرفين الى المفاوضات
نهايه الموجز الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]